this is he was one of the world's most
wanted fugitives 84 year old felicia
akka Booga the man accused of financing
the militias that massacred 800,000
people in 100 days during the Rwandan
genocide until his arrest in France he
had been on the run from international
justice for 25 years
kibou gir had been indicted by the
United Nations International Criminal
Tribunal in 1997 on seven counts of
genocide but the former businessman
managed to avoid arrest using his
powerful international connections to
evade capture
kibou gir always had very close
relations with with Mitterrand
government in France he's very
well-connected in elite circles in Paris
and I think his arrest today will also
raise questions about how much safe
harbor he has received from the French
government in recent years kibou gir had
been living under a false identity in
this apartment in as near co-sin near
the center of Paris he had previously
lived in Germany Belgium the Democratic
Republic of Congo as well as Kenya and
Switzerland what are some authorities so
people school this morning we were
surprised because when we went
downstairs like all the neighbors we
were trying to get out and then we saw a
whole army of police preparing this
operation his son-in-law had been
arrested in Germany in 2007 for war
crimes committed during the 1994
genocide the US had offered a five
million dollar reward for information
leading to his arrest
kibou gur had also been the chairman of
the infamous f - LM radio station which
he used to broadcast propaganda inciting
ethnic Hutus to murder Tutsis his arrest
was carried out by French police
together with cooperation from Belgian
and British authorities now he will face
the International Criminal Court in The
Hague for his part in one of the worst
atrocities in recent history
Sonia Gallo al Jazeera Lewis Mudd is the
central Africa Director for Human Rights
Watch he says this is an important
moment for victims of genocide
this is a huge day for Rwanda and and
this is a huge day for international
justice and it's very difficult to
overstate how significant this arrest is
for this yank Abuja is one of the big
fish he is one of the last remaining
individuals out there who really had it
was alleged to have have excuse me
a real planning purpose with regards
through one and genocide and for many
years folks like myself thought maybe he
was going to get away with it maybe we
would never find him there was rumors of
him being in Europe and East Africa for
years so to wake up to this news is
incredibly significant and I can't
imagine how relieved and and I don't
want to use the word happy but how
resolved people in Rwanda survivors and
victims family members of victims of the
genocide must be I think there will be
questions asked and I think they
absolutely should be the fact is is that
Felician kabocha is not someone who was
unknown there was a massive reward out
for him for many many years he has been
at the top of the arrest the the sort of
most-wanted lists of not only East
African countries but also European ones
so I think there should be an absolute
investigation as to how he was able to
get this other identity and how he was
able to evade justice for 26 long years